we got news ladies and gentlemen we have
information on the Trump indictment
breaking Trump indicted reportedly on 34
counts related to falsifying business
records the indictment stems from Trump
allegedly falsifying records concerning
130 000 payment to Daniels Stormy
Daniels in 2016. CNN reports they were
informed of the number of indictments by
an unnamed source so we we take that um
with grain of salt Trump's former
attorney Michael Cohen pleaded guilty
yada yada let's play the clip from CNN
do we have audio here my sources that
this is 34 counts of falsification of
business records which is probably a lot
of charges uh involving each document
each thing that was submitted as a
separate count in a couple of matters
okay well that's it is that like if he's
like yeah and then he responds it has to
be more than that
more than what it has to be more than
just counts of falsifying business
records I think it has to be something
election related to keep it to go past
the misdemeanor thing I think I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna agree I I think it's
definitely going to be more than just
the Stormy Daniels thing falsifying
business work is that like if they're in
an email chain and he's like are you
sure and then he sends an email he's
like responds yes and then he's like
okay then is that three counts my guess
is gonna be that I think he was paid
back wasn't it over a multi like a year
period or a two year period the
falsifying business let's say that I
paid you bi-weekly over an entire year
right it would be 26 different payments
that I'm lying about so it'd probably be
26 separate counts of falsifying records
that'd be my guess but again it has to
be more than just falsifying records
because that's only a misdemeanor and
the statute of limitations expired and
it's a misdemeanor we charge a
president over experts that's the most
insane thing
from conservatives it has to be
something more than that
um it has to be something more than that
but I agree I think they're gonna it's
gonna be worse than people think right
now everyone's saying it's a Stormy
Daniels thing I bet it's gonna be
something else something completely
different I don't know about completely
different but it's going to be it's got
to be really like campaign fund
misappropriation or the question is
something will it be dubious or will it
be questionable or will it be airtight
you know what I mean I kind of feel like
it's probably going to be dubious I mean
Ukraine gate as it was and and and
Mueller and Russia and all that stuff
did not pan out I have very little in
terms of indictments there are a lot of
good indictments that came from the
normal investigation no I mean like
Trump isn't a Russian spy he wasn't
working with the Soviets oh probably
like though like they nothing was born
of those things
you know I mean I feel like this is just
like they're gonna spin their wheels
Trump's going to fundraise off it he's
going to raise record number amounts of
money there's going to be a mug shot
that will turn into t-shirts people will
get rich off of it Donald Trump will win
the election in 2024 and then we'll not
even talk about this moment later on
does this kind of thing give people the
right to go deeper into his life and
look for things and serve subpoenas and
warrants and things to like look at
emails from 20 years ago does it open up
old I would hope that prosecutors are
being intelligent when it comes to
charging somebody that's going to run
for president it's not even the fact
he's a former president said he's going
to run for president the absolute worst
case scenario for the health of this
country is that Donald Trump gets
indicted charged and convicted of
something that's not really that big of
a deal that somehow inhibits his ability
to run for office because now you've
Justified every single conservative that
thinks that the system is trying to keep
him out using judicial means the left
doesn't even get to feel good because
like let's be honest let's say he goes
to jail for something really stupid like
lying about you know paying off a porn
star like you don't even focus like I
want to him to go down for like the P
tapes for the proof of stuff right not
for not for this so uh or BS so
uh yeah no I I hope they're sitting on
something good otherwise I have to
realize that making the entire United
States look like a joke I I don't think
there's going to be anything there I
mean it's been years they've known about
this for years and they've not done
anything so it really just feels
politically expedient and they just
disbanded the grand jury two days ago or
something for today they announced it
was going on break for a month oh by the
way that's so weird
I I have a question for you Stephen if
it's kind of off topic but it's somewhat
on topic like this I'm talking about the
war in Ukraine and the Russian war what
do you think is the solution to ending
this or to the Future well wait wait
hold on hold on first question is how do
you feel about the war in Ukraine uh I'm
happy Ukraine is winning I hope they get
back Crimea Russia
so what do you think would be a solution
to make that happen
um Ukraine winning the war and getting
back Crimea and saying Russia how
would what's Define winning the war
getting bad Crimea
having their borders restored to what
they were in 1991 when they broke off
from the Soviet Union and when the
entire world recognized the country as
having the borders that it did that
included the donbass and included uh
Crimea
oh man well there's a lot of people some
of my friends think that same thing
what's what's what's the I suppose
justification for U.S involvement
um justification for U.S involvement is
probably that like the stability of
Europe is potentially at risk that we
are seeing an actor engaged in actions
that haven't happened in decades where
one sovereign state invades another
sovereign state to steal territory from
them it's just something that we don't
really see around the world anymore
especially in Europe and I think that
the opposition to that should be led by
the United States I think it's important
a leader of the world to do that would
you be in favor of a similar military
response if it came to Taiwan
uh Taiwan and Hong Kong are so much more
complicated and I'm not well versed
enough in the history to know if I would
feel the same for that
um the stability of Southeast Asia and
the region you know what I mean um true
but I think that our responsibility
presence we have in the relationships we
have with southeast Asia I mean we do
have good relations with South Korea and
Japan but it's different than than
Europe but um I would have to read up
way more on Taiwanese history and the
deals that China has carved out with
respect in the autonomy of Taiwan to
know if I would feel the same way about
defending them militarily versus Ukraine
but I feel very strongly about Ukraine
understand the Ukrainian history and
everything that their borders should be
respected do you think the 100 billion
dollar price tag is Justified
um I I think a really big price tag is
Justified I mean I'm not going to sit
here and argue to know the difference
between like 100 billion versus you know
1 trillion versus 500 billion
um dollars but I think that it is worth
it for the United States to be making
heavy investments into the security of
Europe I think that that position that
we have is like the leader of the
western world and leading those efforts
to predict Ukraine is really important
would you go to Ukraine and fight the
Russians no would you send me did
you send other people's kids there to
fight Russians um U.S troops in Ukraine
fighting Russians is
probably something I would not support
but what about what about Special Forces
doing operations to assist ukrainians
um
I don't think so well what about I'd
have to think a lot like what does
Special Forces mean like if we're
talking about like people going over to
like train troops maybe like for
instance if we're sending weapon systems
over there and we're sending troops over
there to train them useless web of
systems that might be important so that
those weapon systems don't misfire or
they're crashing planes and they did
some um they did do it one time yes
they did what about the U.S using uh
reconnaissance measures and surveillance
to provide intelligence to the
ukrainians to then have the ukrainians
use the weapons we provided to say sink
the Russian Flagship in the Black Sea I
think so far I think that's been fair
game I think that a lot of people around
the world share intelligence that's
probably just a given at this point of
sharing intelligence with Ukraine is
probably no difference than than China
or Russia sharing itself with each other
as well what about former U.S military
now veterans fighting on the ground in
Ukraine using U.S intelligence U.S
weapons and U.S funding to assist
ukrainians and say like sinking ships I
think it's it sounds silly but I think
there is a distinction that they are
former US military the scary part about
U.S troops and Russian troops shooting
at each other is the potential for
escalation into all of us getting blown
up but if a former U.S military person
gets killed by a Russian troop that's a
Ukrainian soldier that former U.S it is
what it is do you really think Russia is
going like well they're not really a U.S
military so we we're not gonna do
anything about it absolutely I I just I
think there's a massive there's a huge
difference between that guy used to be
um part of the U.S military spreading
Ukraine versus there are armed U.S
troops on the ground there's a whole
escalatory pathway for U.S soldiers in
Ukraine Putin cares absolutely I mean
they just took down one of our drones
whether it was an accident or not they
did a fuel spray on it sure and then
when we do dumb like that to each
other sometimes it happens but
um they're having uniformed US troops on
the ground Ukraine would be a massive
escalation do you think Russia is going
to allow Ukraine to win
is Russia going to allow Ukraine to win
um well I mean they've allowed them to
get as far as they have so far but now
they're positioning nukes north of
Ukraine and Belarus um I Heard the the
Strategic nuclear weapons being moved
into Belarus
um I don't know why I don't know if
that's a posturing the UK is deploying
you depleted uranium tank Busters which
are radioactive
Russia responded by saying we warned you
that if you use depleted uranium that's
nuclear escalation and now they're
moving nukes sure but they've been
they've been talking about nuclear
escalation for like two but then they
did it and now Russia is sending nukes
into the region sure they into Belarus
yeah but like are they actually going to
start using I don't think Russia is
going to I don't think so I don't know
how she's going to use it the mistake
people make is they assume nuke means
you know 100 Megaton ICBM doesn't happen
even strategic nuclear weapons I think
would be a nuclear artillery
unbelievable depleted uranium is
different than firing nukes no I'm
talking about explosions I'm talking
about nuclear shells I'm talking about I
don't think they're going to be part of
you I don't think they'd be firing small
yield no Davy crocketts no exotic
miniature nuclear arms I don't think
that'll happen that would be an I don't
even think China I don't think anybody
would support Russia and those types of
actions I disagree
I think that China would support Russia
you think that yes hands down wow I
think the U.S has already lost its
position Brazil was it Brazil and China
just uh announced that they're going to
be trading outside of US Dollars yeah
China's brokered a deal between what
Iraq Iran and Saudi Arabia like the U.S
is in such a fractured position right
now that I'm pretty sure China is going
to be like sucks to be United States I
don't think it's about being in a
fractured position I think it's about I
don't think anybody wants to be in a
country where people are shooting
nuclear weapons including China and
everybody else in the world but that's I
think it's going to be in Ukraine this
is what I'm saying the U.S will not uh
this was this was brought up by uh I
think it was it was a new politician he
said if Russia uses lower yield nukes in
Ukraine the West will not respond with
with with with similar nuclear weapons
or greater why would who cares what an
EU politician says though he said uh no
who was this it was it was it was it was
like a U.N guy or something I don't care
who it is if it wasn't the U.S president
no no one is going to risk what
did he say no one's going to rest
um like Warsaw for Kiev no one no one if
if if Vladimir Putin escalates the
conflict in Ukraine Western forces will
not escalate to the point where they
would put their home countries at risk
they will keep the conflict in Ukraine
well of course but that's Ukraine's not
a NATO country so all we'll do is send
stuff to help but we're not going to be
putting troops there we're not going to
be flying planes over there what they
were saying is that Putin uses nukes in
Ukraine the West will not fire nukes on
Russia in return fire nukes and Russia
return I don't believe so but didn't
wasn't Biden's initial claim that we'd
be like uh we'd be um destroying like
their Fleet in the Black Sea or
something if they were doing well we
took out their Flagship
um yeah I mean but again I wouldn't I
wouldn't look to a un or an EU
politician to speak on behalf of the US
military or what the U.S is willing to
do because at the end of the day that's
really all that matters right I agree
with your principle the country
shouldn't be invading and colonizing
territory but then I look at what the US
did the last 20 years in Iraq we haven't
done anything even remotely similar
um they're not on our border we have a
puppet state in Iraq we have
corporations set up Iraq holds their own
elections they Iraq is its own country
we didn't take any terrorist story from
them we didn't declare any of this like
this is now part of the United States
it's a totally different scenario from
what's happening in Ukraine Russia we
removed the bath party from Power which
caused Isis to appear you know but I
mean you could say it's it's legit but
it's the puppet state I'm not saying
it's legit but it I don't think they
call it a puppet state I don't think
it's fair they hold their own elections
it's they are their own country we might
like it we did remove Saddam Hussein we
did ban the bath party from reforming
that is true but we didn't take
territory we didn't come in and said
like we're gonna carve off this part as
like new Connecticut right it's part of
the United States now that's an insane
thing to do yeah that's an insane thing
to do we have we haven't done that
Russia went into
um Ukraine and they took territory this
is Russia now that hasn't happened in so
long that's that's a it's an
unprecedented action in this age post 91
both Soviet Union that's insane yeah I
think of it as like after the Soviet
Union broke up the oligarchs split it
all up and they took away the warm water
port from Russia because they didn't
want to be a global hegemon they were
like no we're going to give Sebastopol
to Ukraine now Russia's landlocked and
they can have their other and it'd be
like in the U.S if they took the west
coast and took a long strip down the
west coast of the U.S and gave it to
Canada and we had no Pacific access that
at some point you used to be like this
is insane and we're going to invade and
take Pacific access and that's where I
see the Russians coming from well but
how they they recognize the Border
that's the country you might not like it
but
it's just de facto like like it's not
day fat it'd be like what if Canada was
like we really want Alaska this is
it's not even connected to the
us we're gonna take this you can't do
that
they could try
if we didn't have West Coast action I
wish they'd try the Canadians
win a war against Canada and it would
give us pre-tax to seize Canada we would
end up taking Canada and annexing it
into the United States no more land
acknowledge the way we invade it over
through Gaddafi we did that but we did
that with authorization through
um through through NATO and even through
the U.N I'm pretty sure Gaddafi was so
bad I think even China was like abstain
for voting no on that one
um but but again I'm just saying that
here's what I'm trying to say there's
something very unique in particular I'm
not saying that like the because I know
a bunch of people swearing out probably
saying oh he wants Iraq and Afghanistan
I'm not saying those invasions were good
I'm not saying our occupation was good
but I'm saying there's something
fundamentally different from invading a
country and taking territory and saying
This Land is mine now even in Ira even
in Afghanistan where we referred seven
thousand years we didn't actually say
this is U.S territory now right there
are people there they ran they did their
elections they do the things eventually
we left but like it's not U.S territory
whereas that has happened with Crimean
you know we almost took Mexico I was
watching this documentary on what was it
the Mexican-American War and then we
like Americans were actually in favor of
just taking it and we won but then the
president of the time I remember who it
was Polk or something he was like nah
nah Mexico can State Mexico the tactic
the liberal economic order has been
using this oh we took Texas and stuff
it's corporate colonization they took
out Gaddafi set up the US dollar and all
these American corporations like like
Sydney blumenthal's Osprey Global
Solutions Hillary made sure that he got
his defense contract in Libya so they
say oh no we're not we're not taking
that land but it is profiting US
massively because we have it set up as a
corporate sure I mean everything profits
us but I mean that's a fundamentally
different thing again from like taking
the land and being like we're gonna I
would argue that colonizing corporately
overseas is much worse than taking an
argument but it's still way different
it's different yeah it's different than
like this is U.S land that we are now
administering legally and you this is
our land now if you legally say it's
okay to invade and take something over
it doesn't make you okay to invade and
take it over just because you said it
was legal thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time